hello and welcome to chris tales
my name is derek neal and i'm very
excited to present to you this upcoming
indie rpg
we call it our love letter to the
classic jrpgs of the past
and by that we mean that this game takes
a lot of inspiration from classics like
chrono trigger
secret of mana final fantasies four and
six super mario rpg and more
but it also has a lot of its own style
personality and charm
rather than just copying those games
we've done our best to build upon the
elements that we thought made them great
to create something new and surprising
for players to explore
fans of classic jrpgs will feel right at
home with chris tales
but they will also quickly learn that
there's a lot more to it than meets the
eye
speaking of what meets the eye the first
thing i'd like to draw your attention to
is just how beautiful this game really
is everything is completely hand drawn
hand animated frame by frame in the
traditional style layered on top of
itself to create
the illusion of 3d movement in this
world
i'd also like to introduce you to our
heroine chris bell who is a young orphan
girl from the city of narim
she recently had her rose stolen from
her and she has traced it
all the way here to this cathedral and
this is where something strange happens
chris bell has a vision
and she suddenly realizes that she has
special powers that most people don't
you see chris tales is first and
foremost a game about the experience of
interaction with and manipulation of
time and elements of time manipulation
permeate virtually every element of this
game
and we will go over a lot of those in
this demo and i'll show you many
different ways
in which time mechanics interact in
unique ways
one of the first of those is what you
see before you right now
which is chris bell's ability to see the
past the present and the future
all in real time all on one screen all
at the same time
so on the left you have the past where
you can see the statues being built
and on the right you have the future
where you can see they're sort of
overgrown with vines
of course this isn't just buildings and
things like that
but the people the places the towns the
artifacts everything that makes up the
culture that these people live in
so for example here on the left we have
old lady magda
who was a young handsome woman in the
past and
on the right we have young marco who in
the future grows up to be a strapping
teenager
every single element in this game has
been built at least three times and many
of them 20 30 or more times
because there are also things that you
can change about the past
or the present in order to change things
in the present or the future
and i'll be giving you some examples of
that in just a little bit as we come
down here we'll see a part of the city
that has been destroyed in the future
this is the apothecary shop on the left
and the miller's house on the right
miller's house and the apothecary shop
they've been destroyed
fortunately we are time mages and we
just don't have we don't have to just
wait for these visions to come true we
can try to do things to affect them
and so we're going to come over here on
the left past
miss june and we're going to speak to
carpenter joe who
was a you know strong young man you know
many years ago
now is kind of old and sickly and in the
future well
things don't turn out so well for plural
joe anyways we're going to talk to him
and see if he has any insight
about the destruction of these houses
yeah good morning i guess
[Music]
so the carpenter lets us know that ash
blight this rot that infects the houses
is typically responsible for this stuff
and if we want to fight it we need some
green leaf tonic
he suggests we talk to the apothecary
miss june about that
so we're going to talk to her but in
classic jrpg style
she's going to want some help of her own
before she'll help us out with our quest
why would someone do this this will take
forever to sort out
so poor miss june has had the labels on
some of her mushrooms go missing
and as a result she can no longer tell
which are the deadly ones and which are
the benign ones that go good on salads
so chris bell vows that she'll help her
out and so one thing that you might try
to do
is take a look in the past and see where
the labels were in the past
unfortunately what you'll see is that
actually it's blocked in the past so you
can't really see
it because there's this box however what
we can do is send our buddy matthias the
frog here
into the past where he becomes a tiny
little tadpole
and in this mode he can walk around and
interact with the people the places and
the things of the past and in this
instance he can actually push this box
aside
and reveal the information that we're
looking for
well this one has a skull on it i
imagine this is the death cap
having done that we can now take that
information back to the present
and we can now go retrieve the missing
label which we happen to know
these kids stole and bring it back to
poor miss june
this is it
[Music]
miss june we found your label so now
that we've uh helped her out ms june
will help us out with our quest
and so we asked her about the green leaf
tonic and she tells us that we'll need
some glow fruit in order to be able to
make green leaf tonic
fortunately i know where some glow fruit
happens to be
this is the world map like i mentioned
this is a
classic jrpg so it does have world map
vehicles
inns shops uh turn-based combat which
i'll be showing off in a little bit as
well the tree i planted
but the fruit is going to take forever
to grow
of course in this specific instance
before we get there uh we need to
recover some glow fruit
what you'll see here is that this tree
does not exist in the present
it only exists in the future but of
course we can send our buddy matthias
the frog here
into the future where he's old and fat
he can get the glow fruit
retrieve it and bring it back to us in
the present
we can take the glow fruit back to june
in order to
get that green leaf tonic that we've
been looking for
i have glow fruit will one be enough
that
and so now that we've given the
apothecary the glow fruit she has given
us the green leaf tonic
well unfortunately we have another
problem here
there's only one dose of tonic and
there's two houses that are ruined
so we have to make a decision do we save
the apothecary shop
the town's medicine comes from here what
about poor miss miller
you know she she has a young daughter
who's going to grow up and it looks like
she's pregnant and has another one on
the way in the future
which of these two should we save i'm
going to choose to save miss miller's
in this house
and what you'll see is that by making
this decision in the present it actually
changes the future keep an eye on ms
miller's house on the right
these kinds of changes and decisions
that you can make permeate
all throughout the story there are so
many different things that you can
interact with in the past and in the
future
and i'll be showing you many of those
things as we move along here
the kinds of decisions that you can make
in this game range from very small like
the color of a house
to things that impact the futures of
entire kingdoms
and so i'll show you some of that some
of those differences right now
so if we come up here we can see uh
young bernard who is trying to make a
living right now
as a street performer in the past you'll
see he always loved to play his violin
you'll see that in the present he's
trying to eke out a living and in the
future
unfortunately it doesn't look like it's
worked out and he is forced into a life
of crime
but depending on what happens to him
that future could change
as you see here now not all choices are
small in crystals
some decisions may affect the future of
entire regions and there are many
decisions to make
which decisions are actually available
depend on which sets of side quests that
you've done
and this is what i mean when i say
everything in this game has been built
not just three times or four
times but some of the things have been
built 20 times because they can have
multiple different futures they can be
different colors they can be underwater
or not underwater
and what you're seeing here is that
certain areas of the city that used to
be destroyed and decrepit
have become nice and upscale and other
areas of the city that used to be nice
and upscale
have become old and decrepit bringing a
bit more of a balance to the city
that used to be one very poor area and
one very rich area
so those are some examples of how the
time powers work let's go ahead and move
on to
the combat so here are the enemies we'll
be facing in this random battle
as you can see this is a traditional
turn-based jrpg
so at the top of the screen we have a
turn order bar that shows you the
sequence in which each of the characters
will be acting
we have enemies on both the left and the
right you can choose to attack in either
direction
you can also use skills and spells use
items to heal your party members
uh defend or pass your turn so that
someone else can act
so in this case we'll go ahead and pass
our turn so that wilhelm can act
in addition to these sort of standard
elements of jrpg combat
we also have an attack enhancement and
defense system
that's based on timing button presses as
you attack or defend yourself from enemy
attacks
so for example if i attack this enemy on
the right and i press the button right
before i hit them
he'll do a follow-up attack that will do
additional damage
it'll do more damage the better my
timing is and in that instance i got a
critical hit
here you can see i defended myself from
the enemy's counter-attack i got it
deflected that's not the best version of
it
but the better your timing is the more
of the damage you'll actually reduce
and of course it's not just regular
physical attacks that can be enhanced
this way
spells and abilities can also be
enhanced and doing that can change the
properties of those spells and abilities
so for example i can use christopher's
fireball spell on this enemy
and if i successfully enhance it here
which i did
it will light that enemy on fire and now
it's taking damage
turn over turn so in addition to the
enhance system we have another system
which is basically chris bell being able
to use her time powers
in combat to affect her enemies so chris
tales is fundamentally a game about
manipulating and controlling time
so for example we can send this enemy
that's on the left
into the past making it into a younger
version of itself
it's weaker but quicker in this
particular state
and different enemies have different uh
benefits
or uh sometimes it's not at all
beneficial even
to send them into the future or into the
past so for example
you might have a young dragon that if
you send it into the past it's just an
egg
but if you send it into the future it's
a powerful dragon that's going to kick
your butt
so you sort of have to plan
strategically as to
what you want to do given which enemies
are on which side of the battlefield
i'm going to go ahead and attack this
enemy here
it looks like wilhelm's getting a little
bit low so i'll heal him up real quick
here we go and now we will defend
ourselves
so this is a multi-part attack i have to
defend against it multiple times in a
row
and so now it's chris bell's turn again
and we can use her time powers again
so this time i'm going to send the enemy
in the right into the future
and that is going to make it an older
version of itself yes but that enemy is
also currently on fire
and so when i send it into the future
what do you think is going to happen
well in the future it's already taken
all of that fire damage
and so that damage all comes in and hits
it at once is one giant burst
and of course this doesn't only work
with with fire it works with
regen spells and things like that poison
as well as
other uh more off-the-wall things so for
example
in the public demo that we have out
there there's an enemy that can only be
defeated
by rusting its metal shield by first
getting it wet and then sending it into
the future
similarly you can have plants that will
grow much bigger if you first use a
water spell on them and then send them
into the future
so there are many different interactions
between chris bell's time powers
and the various status effects and
ailments that can be applied to enemies
during combat now um
this is not the only system that adds
complexity and depth to what's going on
in the combat
there's actually more even on top of
just this
so there's also a system called the
syncro system and there i failed to
defend myself
but there's also a system called the
syncro system which i'll be showing off
now
which allows chris bell to use her time
powers to speed up an
ally so that he can create crazy combos
so for example here uh we'll invoke the
syncro
with wilhelm and uh do his yuka reign
and have him uh heal the party and
send a whole bunch of exploding plant
bombs at this enemy over here
and so here you'll see chris bell using
her time powers to accelerate wilhelm
and let him take a whole bunch of
actions all at once
boom and so uh we can go ahead you'll
notice when you're attacking across time
you send out an astral projection of
yourself
as well so the synchro system allows
chris bell to
set up combos with her different
characters so for example
christopher here has a water spell which
gets enemies wet and makes them more
susceptible to lightning
and also has a lightning spell so you
can set up a combo with him
that involves starting with the water
spell and then
proceeding into the lightning spell for
extra bonus damage and then you can
follow up
or you could light the enemy on fire and
then follow up by sending them into the
future with chris bell
things like that these systems provide a
huge number of possible interactions
between all of the different characters
and a huge number of different ways in
which you can approach each battle
of course this is only a small glimpse
into the full game
the final product will be over 20 hours
long and contains dozens of enemies
unique powerful bosses and a complete
world full of different kingdoms to
explore
we hope you're as excited to experience
it as we are to be bringing it to life
thanks and have a great day
[Music]